do you not think there's Universal
standards of beauty when everyone walks
into the room you don't think everyone
has a general perception of who's more
beautiful and less beautiful they even
take us in the room you don't think most
of us like they could say who's more
beautiful and less beautiful you don't
think in general you know who the pretty
friend in your friend group is she's
thinking of uh you say always women's
perspective so if a man is a bit ugly
but he has a lot of confidence in the
woman's eye he becomes more so that's
how women view other women okay because
she confident is more attractive but men
don't look at women like that just
because she confident she doesn't become
more attractive